normally we do this like uh four rounds
in the morning it takes about 20 minutes
so now we do one round about five
minutes is gonna take
okay this will be anybody want a sore
get a mentor
so today let's learn from one of the
best wim hof and the breathing technique
that will 10x your health
mentor me whim
whim teach me some briefing right now
show me some so i can demonstrate it
all right um you got a clock here
this uh so get me the timer on you got
it
right i want you to go within two rounds
up to two and a half minutes without air
in your lungs no i can't do that i can't
do
yeah yeah only die and but then re-ink
on it
what if i don't come back as a guy with
this haircut oh no
so that's two minutes you have to just
press start okay
so tell me what to do let's do just one
round
and about two minutes without breathing
you will stay
okay and without in your lungs okay
normally we do this like four rounds in
the morning it takes about 20 minutes
so now we do one round about five
minutes is gonna take
okay this will be in anybody is able to
do this uh uh
along on a sofa or sitting
safely like you are sitting uh now and
or but
don't do this in water don't do this
behind
a wheel of a car because
you really get into past your
conditioning
pass your consciousness you can go
and there's nothing going on it's great
what is going to happen
your body becomes very alkaline which is
just a newly been proven in a scientific
research
be going to be published very soon is a
lot
related to this how simple it is how
many complications will go away if you
only do this
let's go right fully in
let them go through the mouth huh
mouth nose doesn't matter whatever you
feel
i do it like this
okay with your mind follow your breath
go on go up fill up your belly your
chest
everything you got boolean
letting go fully
letting go we will do 30
30 breaths we almost got 10.
really end letting go
relax fully in
then you let go pull it
letting go it's all all right fully in
letting go here is the meditation here's
the going deep
even people meditating for years are not
able to go as deep as we will go
now angle
go with the flow like the sea
waves getting to the shore then letting
go
and there it comes again julie letting
go
seventeen boolean letting go
fully letting go
fully air letting go
you feel light in your head losing your
body tingling
it's all all right breathe into it
breathe into it
intensify whatever you feel is different
we are charging up the body
we want to go into the depth we are
charging up the body
yes 23 seven more
fully in let it go
fully air
two boolean
one here comes the last one fully
[Music]
let him go and stop after the exhalation
just witness
feel the feeling the rush it's your
blood in your nervous system
charges there is no need for breathing
whatsoever
it's no hypnotizing just the
magic of the physiology at work
now we are your body your nervous system
is getting into the brainstem
slowly and surely
oxygen levels begin to decrease
rapidly does the brainstem is beginning
to answer hey there is no oxygen but you
are
alkaline your chemistry is right so
there is no need for breathing
but the crocodile doesn't understand he
says
i have to survive adrenaline shoots out
you get a reset to your primordial state
wherein the immune system
suddenly is within the reach of the will
and it's happening all what is not
necessary in the body
the wrong cells cancer cells half cells
it is being expelled because you need to
be in function
a danger is happening the body goes
into this autonomic nervous system state
of being
to be the best of yourself and you are
doing it
all consciously you are at ease
this is the way we get into the deepest
and take over control in the
neurological pathways
right over there blood flow is going
into the depth into all the parts of the
brain
any brain scan is able to tell that
so there it is
okay breathe in and
breathe in and hold
and squeeze to your head
ten seconds ten nine eight
seven six five four
three two one let it go
that is one round
now this is what these people did in the
hospital
and then the bacteria had no chance
how simple it is and when we are dealing
with
inflammation causing depression in the
end
we take away the inflammation with
doing this within a quarter of an hour
and people feel
re revived of their
depression and depressed state
so it's a it's a cure for anything
because we
are built to be able to prevent and heal
from disease
both physical and mentally and this is
the way
now i've got a special bonus clip from
wim on how to breathe
and believe that i think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action
here we go question number one when can
you
do this breathing again later today
number two
how can you make this breathing a part
of your daily routine
and number three who can you involve to
make it fun and hold you accountable
there's a lot of unnecessary suffering
going on
just because people believe the wrong
things
they believe in pills who believe in
medicines they believe
depression cannot be tackled they
believe you cannot enter into your brain
and i tell you we found a way to get
back to yourself
but get back to mother nature within us
and make some
sense within yourself you are the one
who is able now
to make yourself happy strong and
healthy
and that is entering in all those
systems just by
by your mind we we are showing this
through
science but do you need science when i
already show this in science with
data scientific results brain scans no
speculation
i tell you but it takes time for
publishing and
and to get it into books and to get it
in mainstream i tell you here and right
now
if you just believe and and breathe
and take a cold shower for for god's
sake because it's good for your blood
system then
you will become in the ability to
realign
with the control within yourself to
become happy strong and healthy
to to control your mood and your energy
management
and all look it otherwise up because
it is simple very effective it's here
right now so
my message to you is just breathe and
believe
if you want to see me at the wim hof
workshop that i went to in toronto go
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i'm the messenger by the way
i'm a man on a mission now i don't stop
until we have no war